it was only a couple of years ago wasn't
it that starma told Rosie Duffield off
for saying that women have cervix so now
he thinks that women have acervix and
men don't and now he thinks that I mean
I don't want the percentage of women he
thinks now have a penis or don't because
that's also changed something in the
last few years so I'm not exactly sure
where they're going except clearly
they are looking for votes and they saw
what happened in Scotland and this was
not a popular policy but this policy
will continue to be contested in
Scotland and in Wales so they were not
United on this
I think it's a move in the right
direction but lots of women I know in
the party and outside the party feel
that we have been trashed we are owed
something of an apology if this is now
the policy